my guest tonight is a fantastic comedian
who hosts the hilarious
working it out podcast his latest book
the new one
painfully true stories from a reluctant
dad is available right now
uh most notable of course of all of his
accomplishments though
is that he is a former intern on my
show yes he's part of that elite squad
of titans please welcome mike brabiglia
how are you mike
i'm all right man we're uh we're we're
dealing with a
couple feet of snow here in the east but
uh yeah we're hanging in there where in
the east are you
we are in i'm actually in me and my
brother joe have an office in providence
rhode island
i know providence i know providence
rhode island yeah
and so that's where we are and actually
we do uh
we do virtual shows here i'll show you
the setup is
we go to camera one we flipped it into a
studio
and it's like camera two is right here
whoa where we have the new jokes and you
got camera three
right here and then here's the super cam
right here that's fantastic that's peter
my producer right there
and uh that's it wait a minute wait a
minute i don't let me get this straight
you have what looks to be is it four or
five cameras four
four check it out
i've been on tv three decades
look at this i got this shot
i got this shot i got this shot
and i got this shot
i have one freaking camera we this is
what we call the around the horn and
you'll you'll relate to this as
being a mass hall yeah this is this is
we got uh
we got valentin to noma nomada fletcher
sledgehammer one move on loses the ball
the game is over
this is infuriating me mike probably
has has four times as many cameras as i
do
we do we do these we do these vet we're
in we're doing these
virtual shows for valentine's day we're
doing
six of them it's like a live stand-up
comedy
show and we created this because
obviously i can't perform
uh in front of people yeah well i it
looks fantastic
i have to say it's dynamic it's
inventive
my hat's off to you because we had all
the time in the world and
and this is uh what we got we're in an
abandoned theater
and uh you actually you actually know
this theater
you've performed here a lot this is the
famed largo theater
in los angeles largo is first of all
joking aside i appreciate what you're
doing at the show by supporting largo
one of america's greatest theaters
hands down and and actually when
when uh when i was writing the book that
you just held up the new one
um my wife and i started merging poetry
with comedy together the book has poetry
and comedy essays
and part of the the process of doing
that was at largo we were
we were i was doing the show in los
angeles and uh
and flanny who who runs the joint over
there
at largo he's an irishman yes he is uh
he is a native of
belfast ireland and i uh
see him every day he's the guy that
looks after the theater and uh and
pretty much runs this place
uh and he's here every day to make sure
it's kovid safe
and to tell us thousands and thousands
of stories
about belfast and five or six of those
are true conan
and but he but he would he
really encouraged them just lean in the
back come here
get your ass over here flanny
lean in it's your friend robiglia hi
mike
hey mommy hi
they're great man so so flanny
encouraged me and jen
cause i i remember i think the first
show we did was judd apatow show
at largo and judd said come do
comedy and poetry and then flanny was
the one
who was like oh comedy and poetry
i like it oh he said comedy and poetry
the only thing that's missing are blue
stars and green clovers
he does have that bootleg lucky charms
business out of the back of the
back of the theater flanny sells lucky
charms that are not
they are not made by general mills and
um
we just have to get the word out it's
like it's like bad meth that's out there
don't touch that stuff kids it'll kill
you um you know what i was
when i was an intern on your show i was
a control room intern and
the one of the jobs in addition to
getting coffee and people always go oh
you got coffee for conan
oh i wish i got i got coffee
for jordan schlansky yes jordan
schlansky
i always keep a photo of him nearby
jordan schlansky has become
uh a oddly revered
a revered and reviled figure because we
started putting jordan
this is long after you were on the show
as an intern but we started putting him
on the air because we found him so
odd and strange and kind of elitist and
robotic and we started putting him on
the show
everywhere i go now everywhere i go
people say
where's jordan is jordan real so you can
tell everybody mike
you worked directly underneath jordan as
an
he's my main he was my boss tell us tell
people what he's really like
what i like best about jordan what i
like least about jordan is it always
seemed like he didn't like me
he does give that impression
but in the end on my last day he goes if
you ever need a recommendation
here's my number i go oh i guess he did
like me i don't know i can't read this
guy
yeah i think he wanted to trap you in
some weird situation
so then i'm being honest with you when
he says give me your number
here's my number call me to an intern
you know you just
you just have to be careful that's all
you have to do so
what i like best about jordan schlansky
and i asked if i could say this on air
because i thought this was sensitive
material is that like
he'd come back from these like very
social weekends
and everyone would go jordan what'd you
do over the weekend and he would go like
well me and my friends would go we
we we went into the mountains and we all
got completely naked and then we sort of
jogged around for a little while
and everyone would be like what and then
he'd be like well we got completely
naked and jogged
wait what like literally like the what
and him explaining it again
kept happening over and over again for
about 40 minutes yeah what people
uh think so many people have seen the
videos i've done with him
and they think that it's an act and that
he's a character it's not
he really is that guy and i can totally
see him saying
yes the body is beautiful it is natural
and he
he talks like spock the body is a
beautiful it is natural
there's nothing sexual at all about
these encounters we just like our bodies
to be free
we like our bodies to be in nature and
so we like to move
through space and time using our bodies
and we don't want to be encumbered by
clothing
so i'm not a weird guy
not even exaggerating i mean that's
what's amazing about it and whoa the
reason why i think
i thought he didn't like me this was my
proof
is that one day they brought in someone
brought in
and handed out conan and conan o'brien
insignia
golf balls and it's a late night with
conan o'brien why i don't
i don't play golf i don't know why some
idiot made those i don't know
i don't know it was not me but i guess
someone made those yeah so they handed
them out
i hand them out i go jordan i go do you
think i could have a sleeve
of conan o'brien golf balls and he looks
at me and he goes
no what and so
and so what i so kind of what i got for
you today is a gift
and and and they can get you over there
this just uh
was handed to me just before you started
uh before you came online
i don't hold a grudge i don't hold a
grudge
that is a
that is a mike brabiglia
golf ball now let me understand you
asked
what 15 20 years ago if you could have a
conan o'brien golf ball
and you were told by jordan schlansky no
yeah
no yeah and then you do that for you
no and that's when i knew as an unpaid
intern
that's when i knew as an unm unpaid
intern in turn
what my place was yeah he was letting
you know
that's so kind of you can i ask you a
question did you just
did you just write your name on pen
[Laughter]
because it looks suspiciously like that
that's a limited edition set and it's uh
priceless as far as i understand it
so maybe donate that one to charity
uh wow well let me ask you this when you
were an intern
and you i know that you were very young
when you interned for us you were like
yeah
19 years old i think i was 19. yeah um
you at the time must have been
interested in comedy
sometimes you know it's hard for interns
because they're so they're told you got
to be professional you can't approach
that's right
famous people were you giving that whole
spiel
they gave me the whole speech at the
beginning
don't talk to famous people don't talk
to the guests
but then uh jonathan katz came on the
show one time and he was from
uh from dr katz professional therapist
hilarious
hilarious comedian one of them one of
the great tv series
of comedy nerds like me and he lived and
worked in boston and my brother joe
who had interned on your show as well
was living in boston was an aspiring
comedy writer and so i was
and so i was like i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna introduce
john katz to my brother joe so i
i completely cross a line and i just
follow i get out of the control room i
spot him after he walks off stage
and i follow jonathan katz and i'm like
i'm going to talk to jonathan katz
he makes a right turn into the bathroom
and i had that fork in the road moment
where you go
should i follow a celebrity comedian
into
a public restroom and the answer conan
is yes
i waited until he was washing his hands
and then i said jonathan i'm mike for
bigly i work on the show i didn't say i
was an intern
but i was wearing a nice shirt and i and
i looked 50 when i was 20. so i had a
high
high hairline you know my hairline was
this since i was
13 basically and and
you could have been a producer for all
he knew i could have been produced right
i got my brother joe's aspiring comedy
writer in boston can i put him in touch
with you
he goes oh yeah he's soft-spoken guy he
goes oh yeah absolutely he goes
um let me just write my number down do
you have anything that i could
you know write it in and i was just like
oh well these paper towels i think
could uh we could write it on and so
then i uh
you know we took out a paper towel he
wrote down his number put him in touch
with joe and joe worked for him for
several days
and uh yeah so i i overstepped and uh
and actually if i i don't know if this
is inappropriate i know this is your
talk show
uh i don't know if this is the time or
the place but i was
uh my brother joe is uh
trying to figure out his life right now
he was an intern for you 20 years ago
and i was wondering if you would take a
meeting with him
if i could give him your number uh well
it's on the line to ask me on the air
it's it's
no wait joe's here now
no that's my brother that's my brother
joe this is inappropriate
it's one thing for you and i to talk off
the air and for me to give you my number
to have joe appear on the show is way
over the line
joe it's over the line this is wrong
i'll show myself out no no joe please
stay how are you joe
where are you i'm well i'm in rhode
island also my home you both are in
rhode island
yes okay uh where and this is near
providence
yes right outside of providence okay big
snowstorm coming down huh it's coming
down right now
okay all right let me tell you my rhode
island story okay now that you're here
and yes i'll do anything i can for you
but
i'll i'll say to you the is this though
joe i will help you in any way i can
your brother has four cameras i have one
i think you're talking to the wrong guy
you ready for my rhode island story
please my grandfather uh had a little
cottage
down in rhode island we didn't have a
summer place when i was growing up so we
would go and we would visit my
grandfather
in the town there's a fancy town nearby
called watch hill
there was this big mansion on a hill so
many many years later i'm walking
through that town
and i buy there's a nice painting of
that mansion
uh on a hill that looks out at the sea
in rhode island i buy it
and i'm like this is cool this reminds
me of my youth my grandfather
hanging out with my brothers and sisters
going to the state beach this is really
cool and i put it up on my wall
lo and behold about five years after i
do that taylor swift buys that mansion
completely redoes it and it becomes
taylor swift's like graceland
literally there's like musical notes on
the gate um
you know it's this big thing people hang
around out front to try and see taylor
swift
yeah i have that painting and i put it
in our guest room here in my house in
los angeles
so these people come to stay with me and
i'm showing them the guest room
and they say what's that a painting of
and i went that's my painting of taylor
swift's house
and everyone's like you're a [ __ ]
freak
you're a creep you're a creep and i'm i
didn't explain
that i had it long it's like i had a
painting made of her home
and i'm going to marry her someday
because i love taylor swift and i'll be
mr swift
that's my story i just wanted you to
appreciate my rhode island roots
joe had one story that i thought was
really funny about being an intern i go
do you have a memory of being an issue
on the show you were an intern for us
what do you remember
i i was and one of the the honors of
being the intern was that you would
once a week it would be your job to
order in dinner for conan andy richter
and the writers
throw their they you know write their
initials
joe you know this is conan right i know
that
i know it's been a long time since joe
a worked for me or b watched the show so
he right now think he thinks he's
talking to a very pleasant middle-aged
irish woman
so so
the question was when i was ordering the
dinner because i you know i'm 20 years
old at the time and you're it's
stressful working
television for the first time like that
and it's the question was
can i put conan's co initials on his
dinner
or would is someone trying to kill him
perhaps
guess what i love them guess what there
were people out to kill me
then and actually they worked on the
same network as me
so yeah one of them one of them was jay
leno i know it's good
yeah which one is his with uh which one
of conan eating wait can i just borrow
it for a second
yeah there you go yeah take care of that
little
right now you can buy tickets to mike's
working it out uh and uh
and this is uh it's working it out
virtually as you can see
valentine's day special on february 12th
through the 14th
100 of the proceeds from the final show
will go to regional food banks including
one that i'm involved with in lawrence
core unum
uh so it really is uh this is very good
tickets are available
at burbigs.com
the new one uh is out there uh
joe joe is going to be prowling uh
just the state of rhode island and he's
available for
various you know uh schemes and plans if
anyone out there is looking to
pull off a heist i think we should get
joe involved what do you say
you can you can spot him uh swimming at
the ymca pool in providence
that's right in barrington in barrington
oh very nice
see we gotta plug in for everybody
that's the important thing
hey guys thank you very much it was a
pleasure talking
pleasure talking to both of you and
thank you for both of you for working
for me
for free and apparently getting very
little out of it
and by the way as i said on the podcast
my dad
since you were my boss i will always
be uh willing to be your intern so name
the day and i will be on a flight
to los angeles to be a conan o'brien
unpaid intern you need to be here in six
hours
i'll be there all right take care good
to see you guys